podcast, margin of error.
You can find it on our favorite
podcast app or at cnn.com/audio.
>>> Donald Trump is finally
hitting the 2024 campaign trial,
starting with what he called a,
quote, intimate event in south
Carolina.
But the Daily Show's Jordan
Klepper spoke to some of the
people waiting to get in,
including these two women, who
insist trump is still in charge
of the U.S. Military.
Yes, I said that.
You heard that correctly.
That trump is still in charge of
the U.S. Military, or at least
one of them anyway.
Take a listen.
>> The military were put in
charge in 2018 when president
trump signed an executive order.
>> The American military arms
that are going to Ukraine, we
have Donald Trump to thank for
that?
>> No.
>> There's two militaries.
>> There's two militaries?
>> There's a good and a bad.
>> So there's two militaries.
Donald Trump is in charge of the
good one.
>> Yes.
>> Biden's in charge of the bad
military?
>> That's exactly right.
>> All right.
I've got my bottle of advil
somewhere close by.
This always happens, Jordan
Klepper, when we have you on.
My head starts to hurt.
He joins us now.
Jordan, two militaries?
Where does this rank in terms of
the more bizarre moments you've
encountered at trump events?
>> You know, it's up there
although, you know, we've
brought people back from the
dead.
There's been body doubles out
there on the road.
Two militaries, it's definitely
creative, but we haven't
summoned people back from death.
So progress?
>> Maybe so.
And what was it like?
I mean when you were there.
You know, trump is talking about
these smaller gatherings as if
it's a plus.
You know, we know trump and how
he likes large crowd sizes, and
we don't need to go down that
road.
But what is your sense of how
his campaign is shaping up so
>> Well, it was interesting.
far?
You know, if you were expecting
a spectacle, you weren't getting
it there.
It was confusing.
There were people who came
assuming it was a rally.
Other folks called it a rally.
Others called it an intimate
event.
There were Maga people who were
disappointed it wasn't a big
event.
There's confusion in the air,
which should be expected with a
trump campaign.
I think overall, there's hope,
at least interior-wise, that
this is a new, better trump 3.0.
Something that should be
underlined with this event is
these ideas were coming from
people who went inside, who were
invite-only.
So the folks that we ended up
talking to out here, most of
them went inside, and they went
inside because they're important
enough to have invitations to be
in the front row of this GOP
discussion.
>> And I know you talked to
another gentleman who appeared
to be at one point calling for
an elevated discourse.
I think we have some video.
But his hat told another story.
Can you tell us about that?
>> Well, it's not uncommon to go
to events where people talk
about the things they want, and
yet there's a hypocrisy that
they wear on their sleeve and/or
cranium.
And that was the situation here
of somebody who arrived and
talked about wanting to bring
people together, that
Republicans unlike Democrats
come at this thing with a
respectful dialogue and they
respect the positions of power.
And yet he was wearing a hat
that said he could defecate a
better president.
We didn't challenge him on that,
but we did challenge him on the
inherent hypocrisy he brought to
the rally slash intimate event.
>> Yeah.
I have to ask you about it
because I assume "The daily
Show" will be covering it this
week.
That is the biggest story of
this past week, the Chinese spy
balloon that was shot down after
crossing the U.S.
The balloon has also brought its
share of mockery.
Let's watch a little bit of
"Snl" from last night.
>> I entertain you people for
four days and then get shot by
Biden?
I can't believe I'm Joe's Osama.
>> I'm actually surprised you're
still floating.
Experts were saying you're the
size of three buses.
>> Okay.
Ouch.
>> Jordan, I'm a little worried
how you guys are going to be
taking on the spy balloon this
coming week.
>> I think with respect, Jim.
You know, a lot of people find
humor in this.
Other people could see an act of
war.
You know, I've checked over on
Fox News, and I saw it purported
to be an act of war.
I also saw it mocked hours
before, so it's confusing.
By I can guarantee you the daily
Show" will take it with the
respect it deserves.
>> I'm sure it will.
Your colleague on the daily
Show, Roy wood Jr., has been
tapped to the entertainer at the
white house correspondents'
dinner this year.
Any insights on what we can
expect?
Will you be outside, you know,
trying to get the pulse of the
people?
I'll try to slip past you
unnoticed, but, you know --
>> I would -- if Roy lets me be
his plus-one, I will definitely
be there.
But there is a better chance
that that goes to somebody else,
and therefore I am outside.
I will happily finger the pulse
of anybody after his performance
and try to get any kind of
negative response that I can use
against him as somebody who is
oftentimes sharing an office
with me.
This one hurts.
This is a big win for Roy.
He's going to be on the center
stage.
So whatever I can do to take him
down a notch, I'll try it.
>> And I'm sure he'll be taking
us all down a notch, which is
also a tradition of these
dinners.
As we're heading into the 2024
campaign and that also makes my
head hurt, thinking that we are
heading into the 2024 campaign
this early on, I mean what do
you think we're going to see?
Are you going to get out there
and see other campaign events
besides trump?
I mean what does your reporter's
notebook look like in terms of
the next steps?
What are you going to be out
there covering?
>> Well, we're excited to see
how this all shapes up.
Nikki Haley supposedly is having
an event in the next week, and
I'm very curious who shows up
for that, what the dialogue
around it is.
On the GOP side, we're talking
to folks about what they think
of Desantis.
Right now even at Maga events,
Ron Desantis is not the bad guy.
He's not seen as an alternative
to trump.
He's seen as a potential V.P.
So I'm very curious to see if as
the rhetoric gets hotter within
the trump campaign, if those
folks find defection, turn
against somebody like Desantis.
If Haley holds any sway.
Who in the GOP is the voice of
the people right now?
I will say from this last rally,
Lindsey graham was there, and I
can tell you it's not Lindsey
graham.
>> Yes, I think you're right
about that.
But we know when you're going to
be out there on the campaign